Why does the room smell different when the rifle is on? I think it smells like
Ozone does the machine create Ozone that's depleted oxygen of the room. The answer
is yes, the right machine does create Ozone. Really mainly if you have the QX2
bulb, you're really not going to create Ozone with the regular bulb that you guys
have, the hammer bulb, but if you have the QX2 bulb, you are creating static
electricity with the back plate on it and you will create Ozone for oxygen. You
are not going to be depleted oxygen of the room. The level of Ozone that you're
creating is minimal. Matter of fact, it's not even really therapeutic. That's
because that's not what you're trying to do. But you will create a little bit of
Ozone. You'll have a little Ozone smell to it. There's nothing wrong with that.
It's not depleted oxygen of the room. Comment on back to this question. Would I take
either back to the pen visual at the same time or take one that different days
take the other? No, I would, you know, whatever you're doing now, go off for, you know,
three, four, five, six, seven days, both of them and then go back on to your to your
same frequency that you were. So give them a break to both of them so that your
body can just kind of reset for both of them.